so let's now look at what happens in the
case of strong consistency a strong
consistency you're always guaranteed to
get the data that has returned from a
put operation towards the datastore API
so when the query is received by the
datastore API it will see that there are
pending updates for the data that you're
querying for it will then wait and then
get the data once the data store back
and has finished and then it returns
that result that's why it's called
strong consistency the results from
queries will always be consistent with
put operations performed earlier towards
the datastore API so which is better
eventual consistency or strong
consistency well that depends on your
application let's look at two examples
the first one posting a blog comment in
this case eventual consistency is
probably best to use this is because the
updates probably does not need to be
immediate and there is no operation
dependency in other words there are no
subsequent operations that relies on
data being completely up to date what
about this one an ATM money withdrawal
well that's certainly a candidate for
strong consistency because even though
you may not like it the new balance
should be reflected immediately and
there may be operation dependency for
example there may be purchases coming in
on that account that depends on an
up-to-date balance you may now say so
why don't I use strong consistency all
the time well remember the use case
strong consistency causes a lot of
weights and locks in your application so
if you want to build applications that
scale you should use eventual
consistency as often as possible luckily
datastore supports both of these models
you can use the default fast and
scalable eventual consistency when
required and when you need to ensure
strong consistency that is also
supported let's see how because it's
quite simple you enforce strong
consistency when you have an ancestor
relationship and your query use filter
by this ancestor if those two conditions
are met all children will be queried
using strong consistency in all other
cases theta
be retrieved using eventual consistency
as we already discussed strong
consistency has a performance
scalability penalty compared to eventual
consistency so you need to look at your
application to determine the best option
for every query situation all right
enough theory for now time for a quiz
good luck